hello everyone welcome uh i'm alana and
i have brought back together three
friends who are very big in the gaming
space on youtube to talk about our games
of the year next to me this way is ralph
you might know his skill up below me
here is young who you know from his
self-titled youtube channel and over
here is jake baldy you know who you
wanted from also his self-titled youtube
channel
uh welcome how you guys doing
yeah just uh excited to dive in because
uh some plenty great games here to
dive into and just oh man it's hard to
choose that's the thing i think it's
been a strange video until five minutes
it has been excellent it's gonna go
great
yeah i feel like this year has been a
very strange year for game releases
because there are a lot of games that
are really really good but are very
niche that are like very specific to
like
i know people who are never going to
touch fraternal who will never get into
that kind of game i think it's fantastic
metroid dread is kind of the same there
are certain people who would just never
play that game so you've got a lot of
very good games for very like select
chunks of people um so i'm just gonna
throw it straight to you to begin with
ralph what's your game of the year oh
man um
i actually to be perfectly honest and
this is not like playing cheeky buggers
i really don't quite know there's a few
that i'm pretty keen on like they're
definitely in my top five but i don't
have like one specific game um i would
say absolutely valheim is huge huge huge
on my list like i haven't even thought
about that
valheim is the [ __ ] uh i think of all
the games that i enjoyed this year i
think i enjoyed valheim the most um if
the fact that this is an early access
the number of things that it nails the
fact that it's made by five people is
just out of this world um incredible
that sense of like discovery and
exploration is just my jam and no game
this year has nailed it as well as
valheim so um that's definitely where
i'm tending towards but then i look at
stuff like it takes two and i'm like i
can't believe people made this this is
incredible and then i look at
psychonauts and i'm like tim schafer's a
[ __ ] genius my god how did you do
this you know what i mean um so there's
definitely some ones that are bouncing
around but those are the sort of like
they're the ones how do you guys feel in
general about like the idea of early
access games being nominated because i
remember that with
pub g i think like it won a game of the
year
like after people had been playing it
for a really long time and everyone's
like wait a minute
but i think that was saying that because
it was buggy as hell everyone's like why
the hell are you giving this game game
of the year it is unplayable yeah i feel
like i don't care
but
if it feels complete enough
you know why not yeah that's fair
for my work it's always just been as
soon as uh they request money and you
can give money and get some sort of a
product
we're like we're free to evaluate yeah
yeah
yeah halo infinite multiplayer it you
know they say it's in beta but you know
the events are happening the
monetization stuff's live like it might
as well have launched even though it's
you know technically beta you know so i
think it's fair to evaluate that at that
point fortnite's been in beta for
forever i don't even know if it's out
yet
it's like six years or something yeah
that's fair warframe was in beta for
like six years oh my god
that was the ongoing meme with that one
i feel like the being able to purchase
it is a good way to
think about it because that is when
you're doing a service to people to
assess it like if they can purchase it
then that's the time where you should be
talking about it that
they're gonna spend their money on it it
makes perfect sense yeah like we'll
we'll do it with like this sense of like
okay they're going to fix this
we'll acknowledge those things like
we're not going to be like raging
[ __ ] but i i still think it's like
if they ask for money
you can kind of you know speak
critically about it
for sure
um jake what's your pick currently just
off the
oh boy uh yeah so i'm still hashing it
out it's like it's like a sword i slowly
forge in
like uh like an ice bucket or whatever
they do i watch that show once
uh metroid
right now comes to my top of mind just
because uh it reminded me why i love
metroid i am you know a fan of the
series
not mega hardcore like i'm replaying
fusion every year or anything it's been
a thousand years
you know i played the the metroid prime
games on gamecube and then that's it
uh i played the 3ds one was at samus
returns a couple years ago and that
started to give me like the oh yeah this
is yeah this is good [ __ ] i forgot but
uh metroid dread really like hammered it
home and
it gave me that like oh yeah i like old
games i like this style of game they
made it really well i think it it's like
incredibly well designed in terms of
uh pacing difficulty training the player
still managing to do enough to always
kind of reward
discovery and i you know playing it on
the switch i'd fire it up for 30 minutes
if i had a chance and every time i'd
still manage to feel like i accomplished
something which was just yeah satisfying
and i thought well designed the fact
that it never points you in a direction
but you can always kind of stumble
into the right place it felt like magic
and i i really like that and it made
samus really badass like just like a
really cool portrayal where they just
like made her pose cool and do cool [ __ ]
and blow stuff up and like look away as
the explosion
i like stuff like that and uh also just
a a really great like
uh
difficulty balance you know where it
wasn't like oppressive but it was like
you need to practice this and you need
to learn and get these patterns and walk
away and come back tomorrow and then you
get it and it's so satisfying like it's
just the right level for me this is
gonna sound like a really dumb thing to
say but the thing that got me about it
was the literal sense of dread the
atmosphere of that game yes considering
what they have to work with hits so hard
like it is
effectively sometimes a horror game
it can be very very creepy and very very
tense and i feel like they just nailed
that from top to bottom which is just
great direction if you have like that
that theme be that consistent through
every single mechanic and every sound
and every setting that's just a very
very good game director managing to pull
something off i have not finished it yet
though
samus also just feels so great to
control so smooth um just like oh my god
like once you get all those like
upgrades and ah man it's it's heavenly
honestly how she controls in this game i
i also always rate a game
when i uh finish it and immediately
start replaying it yeah i that always
like ticks up a couple points in my book
and with dread i did that so
that helps that's
so hype i just i love the way that man
that's all i'll say does that mean that
that that metroid dread is high up for
you too oh man see this is this is a
struggle i have a couple in my head i
like that everyone's like i don't know
who works previously i was just like
it's sakura everybody shut up
yeah and now that jake brings that up
maybe metroid should be higher i don't
know but i say for now the one that
really sticks out to me is it takes two
that's the one that gave me that sense
of video games are magical when it can
accomplish this that sense of like
wow like this new thing happening here
and it's just it reinvents itself
constantly this game
and it does so to a degree that i just
wasn't expecting out of you know an
indie title if you will it's crazy that
just a small group of people made this
thing and added so many gameplay
elements that all work and kind of uh
are linked together in a really
well-paced way and it's there's just a
constant sense of wonder with that game
that i haven't gotten in a very long
time
the thing just that feeling the thing
that gets me with that game is
they have so many mechanics yes
how like calm down stop it just calm
down
snowboarding game
it's like a downhill genre like a diablo
game yeah yeah third-person shooter and
they virtually all feel good and and
you're excited to try every new one it
is actually mind-blowing that they have
managed to have i don't know maybe 20
games in one yeah that they design
systems for every time that they
tutorialize effectively every time so
that you understand it with another
person
and now there are those like little mini
games you can compete with the other
player again all scattered throughout
and those are their own little like
little genres and games within
themselves and it's just there's so much
variety in this game and you are you're
always looking forward to the next thing
and nothing has hit me as hard as that
elephant scene still nothing this year
no one ever talks about the elephants
move over the last of us giraffe scenes
seriously elephant scenes come to play
the most traumatic scene of 2021 in two
years
is this spoiler by the way are we doing
spoilers on this
are
[Music]
yeah okay fair enough well then it's
impossible to talk about that saying
that it exists and was it exists and
it's [ __ ] up yeah yeah you'll
get there you'll know i would actually
be very happy if it takes two one at the
game awards so i think i like all the
nominees um if it won i feel like that
would be such an unusual pick literally
unusual in terms of previous winners
they're generally always a big narrative
single player experience with the game
once yeah and i mean yeah it's
technically not triple a i mean it's ea
published but i believe it's part of the
originals program exactly um which is
awesome like and and joseph ferris after
like how we we saw him at the game
what's last year i wanted to come back
in and [ __ ] the oscars again it'll be
great but i i would i would be stoked if
it won um even if it is not my pick for
game of the year because i feel like it
is such a technical feat i don't know
how that game was made i don't know how
they did it and then the fact that it's
also required co-op and that your second
player gets the game for free as well
it's just awesome yes yeah
it's super impressive it's very
wholesome yeah yeah i i just want one
here i just won an indie game to take it
because so many indie games deserve it
honestly at this point um and it takes
two is is really up there among the
greats uh i i think ratchet and clank is
the one that might take it personally
like in terms of like what i think the
consents will be at the game no way i'm
so not i don't think so really what do
you think are you hearing that oh i
don't know but i think definitely
oh man really yeah whoa let's talk about
that yes i think so my pick for game of
the year is inscription
um if you guys haven't played it uh de
vulva published yeah
fantastic and
oh
in a way that i'm like the fact that
none of you have played it is the most
exciting news that i've heard all week
oh my god um so it looks it looks like
magic the gathering you start playing it
and it's a creepy magic the gathering
mechanically very similar it is a card
game until it's not and there are so
many until it's not moments that you're
playing through inscription and you're
just like oh my god it's fascinating
it's brilliant i highly highly recommend
you guys try it it is it is my game of
the year and it's wild because i just
got a code from devolver i didn't know
what it was i tried it it was like sure
i'll give it a shot
and then i maybe put six hours in and i
was like
holy [ __ ] it's really really really good
um my other front runner is death door
which is also devolver
um which i play it
also really lovely
indie-ish i don't know if they count as
indie if they're published by a devolver
or published by each i still think the
studio is that's an indie label i think
yeah yeah yeah i think so death door was
made by
a really small team two people yes i
think like two core people and then like
five or six supporting and then like a
few more people around that but it was
definitely sub 10 people yeah and i
think the core of it was like actually
two people have you played it yes how
did you like it
i i liked it i definitely didn't love it
as a lot of as much of as much as other
people i think the soundtrack was
incredible it's probably my favorite
soundtrack of the year actually just
that piano the way it carried it um i
just feel like the combat side of it
just sort of kind of
yeah i don't know i never clicked with
that i never felt like oh i really want
to continue playing and fighting stuff
and that's fair you know what i mean
like so i definitely liked a lot but
it's definitely not on my game of the
year list this year that's fair i i
absolutely loved it design story i love
the combat as well um top to bottom i
thought it was awesome
um death loop is in there for me too and
so is returnal
but inscription is my number one and i
think it's nominated under indy but i
feel like there's no chance that it gets
anything at the game once it's too small
like none of you have played it most
people haven't played it no no but like
i really feel as though everyone that
i've spoken to that has played it has
said this is
my game of the year or it's up there
like it's definitely got that brand that
kind of like cult recognition that might
be able to carry it over the line
because i'm looking like what else is in
that category in that category is 12
minutes whoa we'll talk about that one
of bridge of spirits uh inscription and
loop hero though lou period did really
well at the start of the year um people
really played that one no neither have i
unfortunately but again people who
played that just loved it it's kind of
like a version of the roguelike formula
um
so i don't know man inscription could
have a look in it's free yes
but that's one that caught my attention
i haven't gotten into it you should yeah
i mean i would recommend it to
absolutely everybody just not about that
let the initial premise of card game put
you off not that it would but i guess
some people find that that off-putting
um gotcha yeah
oh yeah that's fair
uh i feel like i think death loop is
going to win
just based on the media love
that's true they're getting so weird
how many so which of you guys have
finished death loop
anyone yeah not me it's a lot and jake
we both put our hands up
sorry no no wait sorry no way hang on
i'm looking at the twitch thing which is
delayed
let's switch over to the live one that's
the way to do it you can tell i spent a
lot of time on twitch
um so okay
like i'm because i'm only about five
hours in now and i'm
kind of struggling that's the tutorial
being five hours into that means you're
just about to start yeah okay but like i
yeah but like uh
look it's not my game of the year it's
not mine but you think it's gonna win i
do think it's gonna win yeah okay and i
do really like it
yeah yeah i just yeah because i think i
definitely saw some coverage and reviews
and stuff and
i like think a lot of what was out there
in terms of you know critique of it
i'm definitely feeling and then i hear
that
like the ai is actually ruining the
entire experience for me and i'm like i
can't believe this is the thing that i'm
playing through it's it's it's so bad
but it actually is just khan it's just
bringing the entire game down like i
actually think there's a really cool
interesting game here if you fix that ai
and make enemies like some identity or
whatever else but also like the puzzles
they're just leading me by the nose
everywhere they're like go here and do
that that is going to do that
and do that
i'm okay with because it has to be that
way for that game obviously arcane knows
how to make brutal ai they definitely do
that well in having the past
in this game because you are repeatedly
going to the same place and seeing the
same people if you were getting your ass
kicked every time and it looks exactly
the same it'd drive you [ __ ] nuts
when you get to the later stages of the
game the breadcrumbing is my bigger
problem is that they really lead you
exactly where you have to go and you
just have to find the right terminology
sometimes yeah
yeah
yeah and that was a game that i played a
game earlier this year called like the
forgotten city um which i really ate it
yeah i really wanted to which i
recommend definitely i had my biggest
gripe with it though and the reason that
i struggled to like go hey everyone
should play this right now was because
that they were basically telling you all
the solutions to all of the puzzles all
the time and it was kind of like let me
figure this out please funnily enough
the developer then added like they
patched the game and then they turned
off those uh or they had an option to
disable those so it's different now so
as an outer wilds fan boy can't be
having any of that
correct the mundo and like at time loop
games it's entirely about like that
experimentation and getting you know
like letting me mess up and figure
things out deathly's not doing that for
me but then there's the other end of the
spectrum which was 12 minutes this year
another time loop game and it's like
dude what do you want me to do i don't
understand what i mean so there's like a
balance there that they need to hit and
right now as i'm playing through death
loop it's not hitting that for me
definitely hoping that it like catches
like it you know that i click with it
later on but certainly that
opening chapter is yeah i'm not gelling
with it you know what i mean i do think
it takes longer than than yeah that
first five hours
and i i really enjoyed it i think um the
style of that game is really cool i
think the voice acting the cast is
phenomenal
and i think learning is incredible yeah
he's such a dude yeah
and i think the um
the uh
learning about each of the visionaries
and why they are who they are um they're
all very well fleshed out too i found
that to be like an exciting part of even
if i do think the game is too
breadcrummy by the end that i was i i
made up for that in other places so yeah
i really liked death loop i do think the
media love implies that it will take it
um
i don't know why i don't think ratchet
would would win um i i think that game's
awesome as well like mind-blowingly fun
and beautiful but
it just feels like
i feel like that genre doesn't tend to
get like that kind of praise huh maybe
maybe
i don't know but i mean i feel like it's
a similar genre to it takes two and um
and psychonauts i just my personal take
on ratchet is it's so beautiful and it's
like you know cool and whatever and but
it's it's it's just another platformer
like we've played it many times before
there's nothing really they're not
really anything very good isn't that
that's a very good one and i really
enjoyed it a lot but you know would i
put it alongside psychonauts is like hey
this is the best that this genre or
video games can produce i don't think
they're anywhere near the same league
like i i really don't really know oh no
no no like no comparison i mean because
i guess they are
it makes sense to pit them against each
other and psychonauts is just
so creative um yeah disheartens me all
the time to see the amount of people who
are like well i didn't play it because
it's ugly
yes yeah because i just did a video on
that and like so many comments like
can't watch this game too hideous i'm
like oh man come on now
look at him guys
little ugly guys people also are the
first to go like oh they don't make
games like that anymore
because it's not blistering 100 240
frames per second or whatever like it
doesn't matter i want to jump jake
removing the conversation from the
gamewords entirely how do you feel about
ratchet versus psychonauts
uh
oh yeah i think i think it's an
interesting conversation because they're
both
strange games that
those types of things don't always come
top of mind uh for like winners of
awards
yeah i'm totally just asking you
personally throw the awards out the out
the window yeah
psychonauts i prefer personally because
uh emotion there's there's more emotion
more character building and more feeling
where uh ratchet made me feel fuzzy a
couple times yeah nice ways and i think
they did such a good job introducing
rivet and making her not like this
annoying extra like it's it's an it's
another it's another ratchet it was like
actually cool and she was great and i
won a whole game with her uh but i think
psychonauts just really nailed the you
know no pun intended but like the
brainier aspects like big time
like
first my personal view is that i think
psychonauts is actually the best written
game that i played this year and it was
very well written what i think made it
so interesting is that it's not actually
about the dialogue it's lev it's writing
comes through comes through in its level
design totally because each area is its
own sort of like expression of someone's
psyche and um and it's never explained
to you like there's never this moment
where you know like raz looks at the
camera and he's like well actually this
is what this level is meant to represent
you know it's it's like you are like
this is what that represents that's
right he has like some southern accent
but like that is the i think what's so
great about you know psychonauts it just
trusts you to get it you know what i
mean if you don't get it well that's up
to you or not i interviewed tim schafer
about
psychonauts a while back and i was like
some of these themes are pretty messed
up
how do you feel about the messed up
themes in a kid's game and he was like
what a kid's gonna care
like the kids talking about
you call it a kid you think it's a kids
game no i'm not saying it is a kids game
i mean it's a kid-friendly game like i
played psychonauts when i was a kid like
kids would be drawn to it yes that's
what i mean i'm not saying it's a kid's
game because it can also be pretty tough
but it's like but you know that that i
think the they don't care about that
kind of thing they're not going to
perceive it you have to pay attention to
it it's how it goes blinks blinks the
time sweeper was actually about 9 11.
so
it's
what
that's scared for a bit i was like it's
been a long time since i played blinks
[Laughter]
oh no
um my only issue with psychonauts 2
and i think we might have spoken about
this the last time we got together is
the amount of cutscenes
um i i have always had an issue
with
when i feel like especially that
gameplay is so fun like even just
levitating on your little ball is so fun
when gameplay is so frequently
interrupted for a cut scene i would way
prefer there to be a way that the
conversation could be delivered in game
play and i feel like psychonauts 2 um
the biggest defender of that for me was
metal gear solid 4. where it's just like
you walk a tiny bit cutscene and then
tiny bit more and then a cutscene i'm
like just choose one just pick up your
good side meanwhile i'm like yes more
yeah yeah me too man i'm like damn i
have to play now
to be honest because i was like what the
[ __ ] is this all right give it to me
but it did bother me a little bit in in
psychonauts 2 to have to put the
controller like and i just feel like
it's a pacing problem it's just
something that i i wish that there were
less of them or that they could have
incorporated gameplay into those
cinematic moments
i think it should be celebrated really
just be because of the miracle of
how long it it took to make but also the
fact that i i think it's bold that they
were just like all right we made another
one oh you didn't play that one from 15
years ago okay well this this takes
place right after it and it feels
exactly the same so i did i did my
homework and i like went back and
started replaying the first one and then
jumping into the new one i was like wow
they straight up we're just like yeah
here's another one
that's cool
for me the i i enjoy the gameplay of
psychonauts too but something about it
something about the combat or you know
jumping around feels a little too loose
i don't know it's just ratchet and clean
just feels better to play but
psychonauts 2 is it's just more creative
i think with some of its level design
and the the the way the the themes are
sort of seeped into the levels visuals
and all that stuff
so i agree with that it's a tough one
for me i i think i like the fuzziness of
ratchet and clank more i just that one's
just one that put a smile on my face
from beginning to end but psychonauts 2
is also
adam the more i think about it maybe
brash and clank won't actually end up
winning yeah i just can't see it winning
yeah i definitely don't know it doesn't
deserve it insomniacs fantastic but i
just can't see that happening
maybe you're right i think yeah
definitely might be it because it it has
been getting so many like surprise like
it surprised me how many tens it it got
from these really major outlets but i
haven't played it so i could i cannot
speak you know to that
but it's good in a way that's
interesting like i really enjoyed it but
it's not a game i would recommend to
everyone like i just have with
inscription like play it oh my god
gotcha
that's me and death stranding i think
it's fantastic i would have to like
interview you to see if this is a game
for you you know
yeah that's totally fair um well to take
like a uh oh sorry go ahead i was gonna
say i'm not sure if you were gonna pivot
towards resident evil because that's the
one game we haven't talked about we have
not i was going to pivot towards return
on but we can go resident evil oh okay
because that's yeah i keep forgetting it
came out this year because yes what's
the year you know no one knows it's
three years since everyone knows i
love resident evil and have for a really
long time and i'm just so happy with the
most recent resident evil releases i
feel like they're like back to back
awesome there were some really good
parts of re8
um yeah how did you guys feel about it
i i don't think it's game of the year
like but it i i still enjoyed it
tremendously um
and mommy milkers that's all
[Laughter]
they really pull from resident evil 4
which you know for many is their
favorite this feels very much i don't
know resident evil 2.0 in first person
in a lot of ways but it's got really
cool set pieces um it's i mean the re
engine just does work you know and that
is one of the best engines i think i've
seen especially for the genre it's so
fitting for the kind of games that they
did yeah yeah and it surprised me that
our engine was used for monster hunter
uh ryze on sunday
and it runs so well yeah yeah
it's just such a better engine
scales well and it's yeah they're using
it for everything now and i totally get
why it's just well you know optimized
and it just looks gorgeous
um and it's used to great effect and in
village
some of the boss battles i thought were
really cool the dimitro boss battle i
thought was really really awesome yeah i
like that one a lot yeah i also the
sound design i'd be very surprised if it
doesn't win that category the sound
design in the game is fantastic this is
like return
yeah that's true that's another one
design is unbelievable that is true
i i i might give it to our eternal on
that one yeah i feel like my thing with
resident evil is
well resident evil 7 i feel like
they have the same thing um
the first
part where you're in the three like
houses in seven brilliant amazing double
boat onwards
cut it get rid of all of it
it took something that was so good like
that first house with jack is burned
into my brain i think i could still draw
you a map of that whole house because of
how frequently i navigated it and how
into it i was when i played it
um but then yeah when it makes you do
the boat thing twice and then there's
that gauntlet at the end and just like
why have you done this i don't feel like
re8 was um as guilty of that as re7 was
but i do feel like the latter half like
the i agree it just is less interesting
um after you you uh
get out of benviento they're the house
which was awesome it was very cool to
see them
yeah that was awesome it was really good
yeah um but after you get out of that
part i feel like it's slightly less
interesting beyond that yeah that that's
for me why this isn't game of the year
for me i think for me it tops out at the
castle that that to me was my favorite
part of re8 yeah and then the house was
pretty great and then and then towards
the end you get a lot more actiony stuff
yeah yes it's all i'll say and i i
didn't enjoy that part all that much um
especially with how overpowered
you feel in that segment and it just
takes away from the tension of what r8
seem to be establishing and all these
things it's interesting because like i i
fully agree that
again for both games it's like the first
half is like perfect like if they had
kept that the whole way through but i
almost wonder if it's so
intrinsically part of the resident evil
dna that you get overpowered as the game
goes on that they are always going to be
beholden to that that's true i guess
like even going back to re2 i mean it
kind of does get a bit actiony towards
the end where uh three for sure does for
sure
it's true but i don't know i think
there's a way to scale it down a little
bit where you still feel a little
vulnerable but still having that that
firepower and i just run it out around
with an assault rifle at the end yeah
exactly it's very different
yeah i feel like my brain at this point
is like broken as a resident evil fan i
don't even know what i want anymore
i really enjoyed the game when i played
it i was like this is cool i got some
problems i got some things i'm looking
for like what's the next one going to be
like this was cool that was cool but
then
now coming to the game of the year like
it might not crack my top 10 which bums
me out
there were so many moments like where it
was like i was excited in the game and
then burned and like the whole
like chris redfield what is he doing
he's awesome he's hotter than ever he's
smoking a cigarette he's got a cool
truck we're finally gonna know what
chris is doing the legendary redfield
and then nothing happens
and i'm like how many times are we going
to keep doing this am i i'm 30 now what
are we going to do
when i think about
chris like
how do i say this without spoiling it
just like why he did things the way he
did it just makes no sense to me uh and
that's you know to avoid spoilers that's
all i'll say but yeah there are
narrative elements that just it's a ton
of [ __ ] that doesn't make sense yeah i
was going to say the central conceit of
that game is putting four jars together
that you know like
no no i'm allowed
yes i have issues with someone being
like make sure you're quiet and then
they effectively give you a tank
right what is it
how am i going to be quiet chris just
what's the plan
just like chris keeping talking about
okay about certain things uh yeah
it's just why so secret if you'd have
told him certain truths he would have
kind of
played along and i don't know just
narratively his decisions seem really
stupid i feel like i give a lot of
a lot of resident evil a lot of passes
narratively um because they're also very
cheesy like so many one-liners but i
like that about them so i think i think
that i agree with you jake is that like
when i think about it that's probably
one of my fondest gaming memories of
this year i had a really fun time
playing through that game i really
enjoyed it but for whatever reason i
don't categorize it with that esteem and
it's also strange because i'm like i
want another one keep making resident
evil i'd play them annually for a decade
and i'm like i love them but i but i'm
not i'm not like yeah but look at
resident evil like pt i would die for
but that doesn't count
not everything enjoyable has to be game
of the year category sometimes you just
want something that's maybe comfort food
level of gaming and i don't think
resident evil 8 is quite it's a little
more than come for food i'd say but it's
still really well made
it's one of the highest rated games on
steam for the entire year it makes sense
yeah i think it's actually in top 10
highest rated games so i have a comfort
food game on my game of the year list do
you guys want to know what it is yes
chivalry ii oh really
it's
up there in like one of my favorite
games of the year just because it was
like in between binging all these review
games i would just fire that up and like
kill dudes in multiplayer where you just
swing a sword and chop dude's heads off
and i'm not the biggest competitive
multiplayer guy i'm actually like
burnt out on how many of these we have
in games as a service games and stuff
but i just kept coming back to that for
firing it up
killing a couple dudes having a good
time even if i was getting my ass kicked
just because like the way the physics
work and the blood and the gore it was
just so fun and goofy and there's like
some light progression where oh cool i
got a new set of chain mail
just right and like throughout the year
consistently since it released i just i
just fired it up for like that that
comfort that like warm apple pie like
pour a glass of whiskey and just go kill
dudes in chivalry it's it's nominated
for best action game this year ah yeah i
think at the game awards it's back for
blood chivalry death loop far cry 6 and
return all so i don't like it's chances
but they got a nomination you know so
it's interesting i mean we all gave very
very very different picks for um game of
the year which is i feel like again
really indicative of this year i think
it's much more interesting you know it's
it is a weird yeah um but yeah to jump
off of that
uh
i guess we know yours ralph but what
would everyone's favorite multiplayer
game of the year be if i'm rolling out
it takes two
okay makes you have to go hang on what
came up multiplayer
yeah
yeah yeah the categories i've got the
category there's like nominations here
for multiplayer game and it is
oh death is counted that's interesting
oh wow i guess it is inclusion yeah yeah
oh no i'm not looking at the gear list i
just looked at releases okay it's back
for blood it takes to knock out city
that like little dodgeball thing from ea
that little dodge ball thing from yeah
yeah you know that one you know the one
yeah monster hunter rice
uh new world and valheim so
uh yeah
but like obviously whatever like maybe i
am partial i've always been partial or
since world i've been partial to monster
hunter i just love that game to death
and rise just i think hit all the right
notes and it's a portable version of
that game and it plays just as well as
world on pc
and even better with it
i i like what they did with the charge
blade and that's my my go-to weapon in
in rise
some of the weapon enhancements i like
um more in rise and that kind of makes
it top out a little bit compared to
world but there are also many things in
the world that um
it's hard i i enjoyed both immensely for
different reasons they're both great
yeah
um
yeah i think i might like rise a little
better if once the expansion comes out
it gets more content maybe that's a
better time to define because world has
gotten so many updates and new content
and expansions over the
years and so it's a little hard to
compare currently but
ryze's changes so far have hit really
well as a monster hunter enthusiast so
i'm gonna have to pick rise yeah i would
say halo infinite i know that's not
nominated but that would be my pick
right now for a multiplayer game um but
i did also love valheim i played like 12
hours straight of valheim and and i
think it's fantastic
um interesting it doesn't look like far
cry 6 is nominated for anything
um yeah he's nominated just before an
action game
oh
yeah best action game and that's the
only game that i can see
see there's actually
yeah best action
yeah it should be on like best ongoing
really because you know it's just it's
just more far cry right yeah
that's true a little bit of a far cry
joke there for you guys
[Laughter]
i had a very middling time with far cry
6. it you know it had enjoyable moments
but
i've played this before i just have oh
totally totally yeah and some people are
into that and that's okay but uh so for
me
i mean i love far cry 2 and far cry 3
like i love them
um i think the issue with
i've also played
everyone after that but i've not
finished all of them the issue with them
is they just why do they make them so
long
tidy little package of the same thing
every year i'd be fine with it but they
did the same with assassin's creed you
just keep making it longer and longer
and longer
i feel like they are still getting the
balance right with far cry though like i
don't feel that they're too long because
maybe it feels longer it was longer no
you're right it was longer you're right
it was um i'm wondering if i feel that
way because i played it before like
like because it feels like you've played
it before so okay
the main story on how long to beat for
far cry 6 is 22 and a half hours far cry
ain't got no business being that long
no
but then
compare that to valhalla where the
critical path is like i'm gonna say
it took me 67 hours to do critical path
of valhalla but and i really very
different with other stuff
um yes it is i feel like it's allowed i
uh i really wish i'm starting to get to
the point where i feel like they're not
i feel like i really feel like it should
not be allowed to happen but i don't
know oh sorry you said valhalla is an
assassin's creed sorry i was hearing
valheim i'm sorry no no no no no no no
no
no
no
67 hours yeah no no no no no
for valheim it can be as long as it
likes i spent seven hours at valham
loved every second you know um but
valhalla after like 20 hours is like get
me the hell out of here and yeah no
that's too much holy [ __ ] that's too
much video again
it is structurally a ubisoft game so it
it feels like a far cry 6 it feels like
i've played that game not just through
far cry but
other ubisoft like watchdogs legions
there are parts in this game where i
felt like i was just playing that like i
don't know i i this is such a common
criticism in you know like games
community circles that it's like it's
not like ubisoft doesn't know i think
it's it's probably realistically that
there are some people who only ever play
one of them and thus they don't have the
fatigue and it's really easy to forget
that
the millions of people who are casual
gamers are the millions of people who
really matter
that even though we're like what the
[ __ ] guys are the same they're like what
i like that i'm dead
it doesn't mean anything that's so true
but it's obviously i noticed
say again jack go you go that was a
theme i noticed even just like with uh
the before you buy comments and
people who watch my stuff was that like
i played five and then i played this and
it was good yeah and and i'm like that's
great because i played five and then
whatever that was
uh new new whatever new horizon new dawn
um i already forgot that's terrible
right but i played those back to back
and then i jumped into this and i was
like the fatigue is still there but i
think at least with six they embrace the
craziness more than they have and that
that saved it for me a little bit sure
sure i was able to get over some of the
big fan of the alligator
oh yeah great call guapo alligator where
the share is the man
i also love giancarlo as an actor which
is cool for him to be in there i don't
think it was his best villain
performance but or his best villain
character uh but it was still fun to see
him do his thing i like the main
characters danny danny rojas yeah i do
yeah actually guys
for once in a ubisoft game
but you know it happened well the old
assassin's creeds did a good job of that
no you're right i mean modern modern
yeah they definitely struggle with that
a lot more so yeah because they have too
much game
yeah how do you even write that you
stretch out a personality across 80
hours and you know familiarity breeds
contempt as they say yep and i certainly
had plenty of that i don't want to spend
the game time with my family for 70
hours you'd expect me to split it with
this dude come on
part of the reason why ubisoft games
have been so samey is the the guy who
approves the projects it was this search
i think esco it or something and he
recently got fired after all the you
know allegations um and everything kind
of got piped to this one guy who would
say
that's a go and that's cancel i believe
that's how it was reported
and so now that he's gone i don't know
if they're gonna change how that
pipeline works maybe it'll pave the road
to more variety but don't think they can
because it's it's not necessarily like
maybe it started as a system of somebody
approving something but it's that they
have all these global worldwide studios
always making games years in advance
that they have to share systems for
their output requirements and tool sets
and everything right so no matter what i
think they can't help but feel the same
and that's the thing that i keep saying
about splinter cell is all the people
who are like bring back splinter cell i
keep being like
you don't want this like sure
it'll be yeah splinter cell titled but
it'll just be another tom clancy
wildlands or whatever i like pain let's
try it
well apparently they're doing it for me
more
yeah but i just i don't think it'll be
at all the same thing because not
because like there aren't talented
people at ubisoft i'm sure there are
plenty but they can't do it the the way
that they function as a studio is just
not compatible with like extreme
innovation because they have to reuse
systems
and they're not stepping back from it
like assassin's creed infinity is coming
it's live service assassin's creed baby
let's go
so i mean we definitely live in we
definitely live in this bubble like in
like the core gaming
commentaries where we're like this sucks
but really i think we're way bigger
oh we don't have any impact whatsoever
at the end of the day like mobile games
are where the money's stuff i want to
keep reminding roblox the last of us is
like all the conversations around the
last part too is like
all of the millions of people who played
this game have never heard of any of
this controversy they have no knowledge
of all this thing that you think is the
most important thing in the world they
have no clue
they don't know what the game awards are
yeah
jeff who what
um related did any of you play life is
strange true colors it's nominated for a
few things no not me
neither none of us i cannot stand the
writing from that's from that student i
also don't like
to play some of it and i bounce off it
so fast i'm like how it like okay no
disrespect to the studio and the writers
like whatever else they know their niche
and they know their audience and it
works but like i really last about 20
minutes before i'm like this dialogue is
so bad i can't listen to any more of it
i didn't mind it in twin mirror
oh that was the one that i bounced off
fastest okay i was okay with it in twin
mirror because in twin mirror it's campy
uh in a way that i found really fun like
i was making fun of it while playing it
in a way that i enjoyed whereas with
life is strange i've never been able to
do it same reason i just don't like the
writing and i get that a lot of people
do um but i also with uh
tell me why like i had a lot of trouble
with that um oh i like their writing in
vampire or vampire because it was just
like i'm dr jonathan reed i'm a spooky
vampire and i'm like yeah let's go
that's good
yeah because they
also made me remember remember me right
yeah that was their first game
i think it was oh vampire what is this
it's come up with a 2010 film with
robert pattinson no earth game oh wow
remember me is it was don't nod's first
game um which was super different to
everything else they've ever made and
did not have that problem um
but i mean the issue that i have with
life is strange is like you can very
much tell that it's a bunch of i think
french
dudes trying to write as like
a specific north west american teenage
girl and you're like yeah
yeah i know about that
but you know i i totally get that that
not everybody feels that way there are a
lot of people who really love those so
clearly they're doing it for their
audience absolutely correctly we just
want that audience
which makes sense um
which i only recently found out i was
pronouncing wrong the whole time i
thought it was hanging out yeah it's not
that's you're australian coming through
right tina
okay
[Laughter]
naturally still haven't played weirdly
oh no way it's really good too it's nice
i like it a lot yeah
i think i really followed under the same
category as like ratchet which is it is
a spectacularly beautiful game that
knows exactly what it's doing and it's
just gonna play all the hits and you're
gonna love it but you know you've played
it before that's it you know it's like
it's not it's not there to win awards
it's not oscar bait um it's just a
really nice video game that i would
absolutely recommend to anyone who loves
those classic 3d platformers you know
like the old
i don't know like i'm gonna say jack and
daxter like those old adventure games oh
yeah um yeah it's beautiful it's uh a
fantastic debut game for envelopes um
animation's gorgeous it's very pixar uh
it it's it's stunning and it's very hot
felt as well it is it is just a really
nice time
it is it's it's interesting because it's
it's a game that you know they don't
make a lot of like simple humble
adventure games like that
now and i feel like this is a game where
i would have like ate it for breakfast
for ps2 or 360.
and now it's like oh wow there there was
we got one this year and it's great uh
but it's it's not like super at the top
of my brain now after i beat it i i was
impressed with how it was like
crushingly hard at the end
oh yeah some boss fights were really
hard it really smiled
the spikes were insane i was like am i
going crazy here
i was like is the game broken yeah yeah
yeah it was in a way that i really
enjoyed though like i liked the
difficulty spikes in it because it
usually
probably not every time but a lot of the
time was after you learned a new
mechanic it was like yeah you go baby
and then you just have to figure it out
in a really hard fight and i found that
really fun
yeah you get through it it was really
the last boss fight where it was like i
was like i don't i don't know man
eventually i got through it but i was
like i know some reviewers have said
that they couldn't finish it and they
really like a lot of people making a big
deal out of it they're like this game is
too hard i'm like oh i had a lot of
people say that was sakura where they
couldn't get past the final boss which i
get
and so they just never finished the game
i feel like you should get a badge for
like
everything but that
yeah right i finished that game
three times that's one game that i went
yeah
because there's like four endings i and
i've uh and i also turned up the
difficulty you if you ring the bell and
do all these things i like turned up
everything and i've gotten so good at
that game now that's made me better in
other games pairing systems and i just i
love that game so much i have not
defeated the um
demon of hatred
neither i that's one that i haven't done
actually yeah i tried and was like
i haven't actually even attempted maybe
not for me wait come on is that the one
i'm thinking of
big fiery boy big fire dude yeah oh
yeah yeah that one's like a post game
kind of thing yeah you don't have to
it's on my bucket list i'll do it
eventually but i got to sit down for a
long time you really have to kind of
back off a lot and then come back in
like well because he plays a little bit
more like a souls boss than a second
robot and i think that's what breaks me
is that i forget that every time
absolutely yeah he's tough
but you've beaten him fun yes oh my god
true game sometimes real hardcore gamers
love security it's a brilliant game it's
mine too i i love and bloodborne
obviously which um
you know
i'm purposely holding off and playing
bloodborne until i see like some kind of
remaster just some kind of 60fps patch
because i'm so used to 60 frames now i
just can't i tried going back
i can't do it
you and everyone else who's out here
like come on yeah come on
i mean that could be like a thing that
maybe you know it's been rumored for
forever yeah announced there's a rumor
that blue point might be working on on a
remaster should be the right people to
do it
yeah i um
in terms of like predictions for stuff
that is going to be at tga i'm expecting
to see bioshock
um i don't know i was definitely
expecting to see
yeah yeah um
the hogwarts game like up a gameplay of
that those are the only things
or whatever is it i don't remember it's
called i don't know i just made that up
hogwarts rising i was gonna say what
hogwarts rising is hogwarts legacy
[Music]
it makes it sound like a star sign
of what's rising
um those are the two that came to my top
of my head what else what else am i i
mean we're probably
we could see more of like suicide squad
or gotham knights
maybe maybe breath of the wild too maybe
i don't know no maybe not no nintendo
won't do that there i don't think
they'll do that right don't we get
usually one little nintendo zinger from
the game yeah yeah yeah yeah we do yeah
yeah so maybe i don't know that i'd call
breath of the wild to a little nintendo
zinger though
there was that one here where they
debuted some breath of the wild stuff
they did
yeah did they okay yeah so they could do
it that would be cool
i'd love that i don't know i'm so
excited for that game
yeah i think next year is going to be a
banger maybe
god of war ragnarok stuff
yeah maybe if only we had someone that
could
confirm that for us
alana has left the chat oh [ __ ]
to be clear i wouldn't know in any case
yeah i don't get that kind of
information
um do you guys think starfield's going
to show up
well they just did a trailer not a
trailer but like a little behind the
scenes docu thing today yeah like seven
minutes of them just did
yeah but like let's be clear it's really
seven minutes of todd and his buddies
just kind of like saying nice things
about
exploration did they say it all like
that
yes they did
it definitely did uh so there was really
it was like concept art and that's it it
was cool concept art to give around like
i liked it but um there's definitely
nothing like guys you have to watch this
stuff building right now there's not a
lot of stuff in there so yeah we've also
got uh dragon age
um
because the last time that we saw that
was the same thing it was just like devs
being like so happy to work on dragon
age and a bunch of like concept artists
oh sure
so that's exactly how they started the
hype uh for anthem as well by the way
so many twists and turns at least based
on what's reported in terms of what it
is it was initially
the single player focused dense thing
then it became a live service now it's
not do you mean anthem yeah
age 4 is live surface it was initially
uh
joplin was a single player game and then
it that got scrapped and then project
morrison
got booted up and that became the new
thing that was going to be live service
and then it was supported it got changed
a single player after how well
single player endeavors did and after
anthem's uh disastrous failure
and uh now and now the dragon age four
director creative director just out of
the blue left yeah project and i don't
know i'm feeling really uneasy about it
personally
i think that's fair after anthem it's
yeah you're on an easy footing for sure
and andromeda as well which wasn't
exactly a home run so yeah um we'll see
yeah i would really want them to be
successful on this one because yeah like
if they're not like you just you have to
worry about the future of that studio
because it costs a lot of money to hire
all those people and they are not making
micro transaction focused games now for
bioware to go down in flames would be
devastating it would be super sad yes so
especially with the announcement of a
new mass effect you know i really want
them to nail that too totally sure
yeah got a lot of love for them yeah i
hope that i guess there's that rumor of
a mass effect tv show as well so yeah uh
you know that obviously would probably
be
a
greater chance of surviving in the long
term if they're going to be working on a
big mass effect game to go out alongside
a netflix series or an amazon series or
whatever it is i do think they got
legendary edition right but that's you
know it's more of a remaster it's still
like they got it right yeah you can [ __ ]
[Laughter]
who'd have thought wow i did not expect
that to go down that way would not have
guessed
neither
dude i was so excited oh my god i was
like hot wait let's go and then i was
like i will continue to wait yeah
but i don't mind waiting that's the the
big thing is i'm like yeah i'll wait a
year it's fine i just want to replay by
city real bad yeah there's other stuff
to play in the meantime yeah um anyone
else got any any predictions for things
that we think we might see announced
i hadn't really thought about it
neither am i yeah no idea um
less less sexy but maybe an actual look
at hitman stuff for the next year yeah
it's more of like a real tangible thing
yeah and i would like to see that
because that's that's on my list of
things that i really like this year so i
don't know how far along double 07 is
but i'd love to the i o games oh my god
i almost forgot they were making that
yeah
that's going to be super early like if
anything it's a teaser trailer i think
so i think it's nothing
i know a fair bit about that game um i'm
trying to think of what i could say
i don't want to get anyone interested
all of it it's just us it's fine
there's nobody watching everyone in the
chat everyone in the chat agrees that
they will not share it beyond the chat
so just yeah you guys will sign up
truthfully i didn't sign an nda's
problem truthfully i don't know
uh how io operates so i actually
couldn't even guess but i know that they
have the story pretty much down um and
it sounds it sounds cool and surprising
and i'm i think nice i'm excited about
it it's such a good studio to make that
game yeah i guess it's further along
it's everything or nothing too
yeah
i mean i loved hitman 3 as well did that
come out this year yeah yes bro what
nominated for yeah so that's actually on
my game of the year it's floating around
in my top five specifically because it's
the only game where i think it came out
in january it did and since january i
kept going in the back of my head hey
remember hitman 3. yeah don't forget
about hitman 3. and i've been able to
keep that in my brain until now so it
earned a spot for me really really
finally clicked i love the narrative
stuff that they they did like i just
thought it was so cool that that uh the
third mission i think in the house
oh the knives out level yeah
oh it's so good
i'm really excited to play it in vr i
think it's already available in psvr but
uh i tend to use oculus and it's coming
to oculus awesome i think it's yes uh
it's pcvr
with this whole 2022
like new roll new stuff
i just want to do that they have a in
the trailer you can you can tap a man on
the shoulder and then like go over here
and he'll turn around and look and then
you can punch him in the face
the only reason why i want to play
that's so good
yeah i'm i'm stoked um hitman 3 was also
fantastic and i feel like i haven't seen
it nominated for really anything but
that's the yeah that's the january 25th
recency recently bias yeah recency bias
is a thing that i feel like i see people
throw around but it like it's absolutely
a thing and it's kind of unavoidable
like you do it does feel like it didn't
come out this year you know it feels
like it came out years ago i think
return was a bit of a victim of that as
well yeah you know like i think if
fraternal came out this month like
returner would be on so many game of the
year lists and everybody would be like
frotting it it is a really good game
yeah i think it's a great game i
absolutely would put it on a game of the
year list
um yeah i think that it is innovative on
many fronts i think it has the best
sound design of the year some of the
best art design i think it has it's my
favorite use of this
favorite use the dual sense looks
beautiful i think the story is really
great and engaging yeah maybe it doesn't
quite stick the landing but like really
pushes you through it all the way um i i
think the combat loop when it clicks and
you get the right upgrades is fantastic
and just like that feeling of rhythm
that you get and like that sixth sense
that kind of kicks in because you start
to feel the battlefield and you feel
when an enemy is about to strike i just
i really think it came together super
well yeah um and i definitely think it
does as a look in as a yeah i agree
i didn't expect to like or be as into
the law as i was yeah yeah i was like
damn i'm super into this i want to
listen to everything it's a yeah very
good
i just wish they had
just improved the the roguelike i don't
know economy or float that's just all it
needed for it to be just like infinitely
replayable almost um yeah but that aside
honestly yeah it's one of the top ones
for me i've also heard a lot of people i
haven't played forza horizon 5 but i
know a lot of people love that game and
many stuff there for me
i feel like that franchise has always
been good
yeah they have always been great it
almost caught me by surprise that
everybody gave it nods this year i've
not played it either jake what's the
difference between or the the big
selling point for this one bus is
previously this one has a delorean in it
i was gonna say that's exactly what i
was gonna say 10 out of 10 game of the
year
yeah that's perfect uh no this one has a
lot more
um
just
active they've always been good at
throwing a lot at you but this one kind
of goes overboard on it and not not in a
bad way i guess um a lot more active
player events that pop up in the world
um i really like the new map i think
mexico is really cool i thought the
variety for it does look really pretty
it's really good it gives you all these
different types of races which they've
had race variety in the past but like
with mexico and with jungles and dirt
and streets and like literal sand dune
deserts
yeah [ __ ] volcano racing like
damn it does look really good yeah i i
haven't played it yet but um
sorry go on you go well i don't have
much to say other than i just feel like
we tend to snub sports games and racing
games yeah yeah and i think as there was
an article that went a lot that was out
recently from a guy named jess corden
and um he was like
the game awards kind of snubs games like
this and focuses on other types of games
that kind of fit into that movie game
category uh and i don't personally agree
with that right but i think it does it's
an interesting point to talk about in
terms of like what game is the kind of
game that we think fits on a game of the
year list i think we want emotional
connections yeah yeah ah
yes i would i would i would agree with
that all we want just like that that
kind of like
but even then i don't know like think
about it overwatch securo breath of the
wild
is it emotional
right i think there's quite a few things
i think we look to when we think what is
a game of the year but i think there's
it's probably really much easier for us
to say like what's the kind of game
that's not going to be on this list and
a sports and racing game is one that
we're going to be like yeah that's not
going to get on the list
sucks
yeah or a mobile game but like you know
obviously forza horizon 5 is literally
the highest rated game of the year
critically speaking uh and it doesn't
appear on a game of the year list and
it's like well what's up with that do
you know what i mean yeah i think it
just doesn't fit
our idea of of game of the year i that
doesn't mean people don't like it and
don't think it's a fantastic game you
know like it feels pretty universal but
um when you think of something as like
the memory you're gonna take away with
you this year sure it's just a different
thing so maybe if it's not emotional
connection maybe it's like
scale
grandeur like something
epic you know that we need um i i i
don't i don't know i do think that's a
really interesting conversation i have
though like i get why it's not there
because i wouldn't put it there but i've
always loved the series and i think
they're fantastic games but i would love
more like game awards considerations
from outlets and you know every website
does their own game of the year thing i
would love if they just kind of all
really embraced the like
the game pro fun factor remember the
game pro reviews fun factor five out of
five yeah like the guy like yeah like i
think they should all have her most fun
game of the year because
yeah because that'd be cool then tony
hawk's pro skater one and two remake
would have won and i would have been
happy and not bitter
than last year but but then like that
that gets games like hot wheels
unleashed onto the list you know what i
mean which i don't know if any of you
guys played that that is a great video
game
super cool video game that if that list
existed i think everyone would be like
yep cool that belongs on there and i'll
vote for it but it's it's not like we're
the only industry to do that right
because you know any film awards is
always like well if it's not about
serious themes like you can't have a
marvel in here you know like yeah we're
doing the same thing and then that that
like green book movie wins or whatever
it's a horrible movie
i haven't seen it isn't it like horrific
to watch no no no it's not it's just
such a generic boring ass story just
like but it's just like it's oscar bait
because it's got like themes do you want
to me because it's got performances it's
got themes so therefore let's give it a
nice stage
it really was just a bit of a low point
i understand
yeah it is interesting to think about
like i i i think i agree with you jake
like and that's the thing that i always
want to want to
talk about regardless is like the game
awards is not
the universal game of the year you don't
have to agree with it it's just what
these people voted on like
whatever you think is your game of the
year is your game of the year there are
a million outlets who'll give a million
awards it doesn't mean anything it's
fine yeah but i would like if we saw
some more creative categories to like
not just be like best racing game yeah i
think the argument can also be made that
given the amount of attention the game
awards draw it can you know if you want
to really support maybe a certain game
and see it get the recognition it
deserves and if it feels like it's
getting you know snubbed and you know
because like game awards no doubt like
can help boost sales of games or for a
game like it takes two it would make a
huge difference for sure
word of mouth yeah yeah all that stuff
so there's an element of that but yeah i
do agree like at the end of the day it's
just it's all
irrelevant what matters is what you like
and it's yeah you like it you like the
thing and that's it you should look at
it as a fun spectacle and that's right
the truth
exactly
i i've definitely heard discussion
around the composition of the
like the judging panel and what have you
and whether or not because you know like
i think there's that people's choice
thing which is totally separate from the
game of the year vote or at least or is
it a case of like game of the year has
like 10 of the votes
toward like from the people and ninety
percent is from game journalist is that
correct am i right and remembering it
that way it used to be that way and now
it is a separate thing if i that's what
i think i might be wrong that's what i
think it is but either way so it is all
on our website broader than games
journalists i will give the game awards
credit for that it is it is content
creators it is a lot of people yeah sure
um well
i'm i'm like part of well game ranks the
outlet i work with is on it so it's not
just my opinion it's our team right but
we are one of the and credit to them
like we're not necessarily like an ign
or a game spot we're like a scuzzy
youtube channel yeah i was on it at
funhouse we were on on the on the jury
right um
obviously
i feel like it would be because this is
something else that quarter article
mentioned like having developers in that
judging panel i think would be really
good uh because you know like you've
obviously got punters and that's cool
but that's complicated because then like
fortnight wins every year okay uh and
then obviously you've got game
journalists and it's like well
we understand that there is often a
divide between critics and you know
punters and then i think if you had like
that game game developer in the mix like
you know they're like 30 of the block
for example i think that'd be good
because these people make games for a
living they really know what they're
doing and they don't know how to assist
you so many different award shows for
that though so i've been on jury um for
like
baftas
that is entirely devs and it's a really
cool jury to do very different to the
game awards because the game awards in
my experience for both the outlets that
uh were juried on it was just
like somebody sent out a form everyone
put nominations biggest nominations got
picked then we'd vote on them
sent um
baftas
is you have to play every single game
that's nominated and then you have to
sit in a room for several hours and
discuss with each other on a ranking um
and then like if someone's like i
thought this game was garbage and it's
crazy how vicious some of the devs are
something like [ __ ] trash what were
they doing like it's wild because you
never see that from journalists don't
speak that way
youtubers do only youtubers
but they they do put a lot of thought
into it so like baftas runs that way um
indycade is all devs i think at least um
dice is all devs uh which is why like
dice uh untitled goose game was a winner
two years ago which was like a thing
that i was like yes that would never
happen at the game awards
no probably
anyway
you're australian sir
but like but
but i but i agree with all that and it's
that's great that that happens but at
the same time i think the game awards
has become such a front and center thing
it's true like it's what our
conversation is centered on today you
know as like the game of the year stuff
we use that as an anchor point and so i
do feel like you know having developers
in the mix on that is a would be a good
thing i think i agree i would like that
but i also
i i think i
would there not be a conflict of
interest no potentially that's the thing
that occurred to me yeah it's not like
it's can't they just be like don't pick
your game yeah that's it exactly and
like it's you know and then you know if
you get like if
there's like a hundred developers it all
gets worked out in the wash one of the
ones that i was on previously i had to
get moved categories because cyberpunk
was nominated and because i'm credited
on cyberpunk i couldn't be in that
category which makes perfect sense so
they were like yeah yeah you're credited
so we have to move you to a category
where nothing you're credited on is
listed um so they they do have avenues
to do that but i do feel like there are
potential conflicts there in any case i
think i agree that i would like it but
it also
i don't know what it necessarily serves
in the end because they are such
different audiences i think that the
often the way that that game devs look
at games can be very different to
consumers and then it comes into the
question of like well who is this award
show for
yeah
well i can ask for the well i think it's
for the whole industry and i think it is
for people to play games the people that
talk about them and the people that make
them and probably you know anyone else i
mean you're right everybody watches
really yeah and so i think if everyone
had that kind of representation i think
they're the major sectors as well like
if i don't know who else you could get
in there
executives need a vote you know the the
directors of you know the major gaming
publishers that's a joke by the way [ __ ]
off bobby potty
needs a boat okay that's right
uh but you know i think those those are
the major sectors like players and the
commentariat and developers and i think
the three pillars i get
yeah i think that would work really well
i'd like to see that so yeah yeah i
disagree um so before i let you all go i
did want to round over to some games
that are still on the list that we
haven't spoken about did you guys play
the artful escape
no everyone's going to talk about that
that was
it's very cool
stunning um sound design slash score is
wonderful
very very simple mechanically um okay
it's more of an experience i think um
but yeah also a really
promising debut game for sure beautiful
to listen to
um marvel's guardians of the galaxy we
haven't talked about that's the biggest
surprise of the year if that was an
award i'd give it that no
my top five
is in emily my definitely top ten it's
pushing top five i loved it and with
some space from it i appreciate it more
and more i think it is fantastic i was
not into it based on the marketing at
all it was like yeah i want nothing to
do with this and then i played it and i
was like
oh
oh
interesting yes yes to me the the
gameplay is a bit too rough for it to be
in a in my sort of game of the year top
10 category but it is the the story is
shockingly good the character chemistry
eventually clicked for me and then it
just got better and better and it but
the way they dive into these characters
and like i i got genuinely emotional
yeah from some of these uh stories and
and how it all culminated and some of
the relationships that peter quill has
with certain characters in the game
it it just worked uh it just i think
this is the uncharted one of you know
what i mean like i love that one was
rough around the edges and then two just
blew it out of the water i think
guardians of the galaxy two is gonna be
incredible if this is the how they
if this is the foundation and they just
build upon it this is gonna be game of
the year easily if they just stick with
it's brilliant how it kind of like baits
you it gets you in the door like yeah
yeah sure it's like james gunn's
guardians yeah come on in yeah yeah and
then halfway through it's like we're
gonna dive deeper into these characters
and explore new avenues that you've
never even
and it's so great for that yeah
yeah i like the the party mechanics as
well i think they did a good job with
the the combat um yeah and and the
animations were really cool like there
were things that i didn't love about it
i don't love scanning environments to
find things in any game yeah i don't
need all that but um i was yeah i'd
agree if there were a bigger surprise
let's just offer it that
for whatever this group of people is
congrats you've won
biggest surprise of the year goes to
marvel's guardians of the galaxy here's
our one award that's right that's it
uh near replicant also was not nominated
for anything other than scoring music
which um
would be my pick for that
absolutely it well deserved ah okabe
what a giant genius
genius i also do love the music of
cyberpunk though i'll give it oh yeah
cyberpunk co2 and i will say of this
this group um it's artful escaped
cyberpunk death loop guardians of the
galaxy and their replica cyberpunk is
the one that i still listen to
yeah same i still like pretty consistent
just mm-hmm same
uh it it's and i mean the just the the
effort that they put in that soundtrack
the three composers yeah and yeah and
they got like bands together to create
unique tracks for this radio or this
game's radio channels and stuff like
that like it's just an incredible amount
of effort and all of it just sounds
really really good in my opinion yeah
this is one that i actually genuinely
give to cyberpunk
it is it is
really good they absolutely nailed it
they were stuck in the genre i think i
gotta give it to okay but but i do feel
pretty you haven't played final fantasy
14 yet you haven't experienced the
geniuses dude when you
once uh once i got into heaven's word
the story and the character started come
together and now i'm like actually
really into it but the first 70 hours
miserable i i hated the first seven
years i don't think you're at all wrong
i think you spotted it but now they're
gonna find the father fantasy fourteen
community don't like you know that no no
no actually the first game is also
genius you just don't understand i'm
like nah man it kind of sucks come on
let's be real it gets amazing but the
first game is not great yeah final
fantasy's had that with us quite a few
games though it was like that with 13
too they were like you just have to get
through the first 20 hours that's right
all right bro all right yeah guys you
aren't playing new world
no anyone no no no
like to be in this defense like new
world's done pretty well for itself like
obviously it's really busted and broken
at the end game as are many love those
like massive online role-playing games
whatever but it's had a really
successful launch and i think the
narrative is quite critical of it
justifiably so but like i think the
biggest story is there was a new mmo
that launched this year at massive scale
that really cut through and did well for
itself it's the last time it's amazon
right and amazing so it was their first
not failure yeah out of like six
projects or something yeah yeah yeah so
i think the fact that they had a proof
of concept that worked at that scale and
got that many people engaged that's a
huge win already and if they can then
fix up the broken [ __ ] and like add
stuff maybe this has got a future i mean
you know what i mean game development
turn off yeah well i mean that's most
games these days when they launch you
know let's be real that's before launch
that's the whole game development
process
well it would be nice if that were true
but unfortunately that's not the world
we live in
so uh so
yeah
i will there you go sorry i was gonna
say i said this last time i i can't play
mmos because i get too addicted so i did
not try it but i had a number of friends
who did and everyone was very positive
about it like more than i've seen
anybody speak about an mmo in a really
long time since guild wars 2 probably
definitely is pretty cool
i um one last thing i'll throw in is
destiny 2 which you know no one likes to
talk about no one has a kind word for
destiny except for old chill up but i'll
i'll do it i'll wave the flag okay
uh i un-ironically believe that destiny
2 is an incredible game like truly uh
it's just impossible to recommend
because of all the [ __ ] around it
so sad i have not played in a year and a
half i used to play every november i
jump back in and i get into it but i it
became too much video game it's it's
it's uh uh look i wish i could just
shout from the rooftop and i think i was
at the start of the year i'm like bungie
you're nailing this man everyone needs
to play this right now but then just
lots of [ __ ] got piled on like
removal of content and the transit it
was the removal that got me out actually
that i was like all right yeah but i
will say anybody who would ever say that
that the mechanics of that game that the
combat doesn't feel stellar is big dummy
[ __ ] here first it feels so good
every time that i ever even lightly jump
back i'm like hell yeah yeah
but i think that's a very common talking
point around it but i feel like in this
last year it's really moved beyond that
like it's live service delivery is
fantastic the story that it's still it's
serving up now is excellent the best
story we've ever seen in destiny the new
content that arrives in terms of raids
and whatever and the classes and man
it's like i really do think destiny's on
a pretty it's it's on the cutting edge
of some seriously cool [ __ ] right now
but it's also on the cutting edge of
some [ __ ] [ __ ] but how much is
bungie paying you though
yeah right
i'm not exactly in bungie's uh like
what do you call it they're good books
it's a love-hate relationship right but
uh
every destiny player says correct
correct correct uh but like you know i
really do think it's totally and i just
think that uh destiny gets a really
rough run a lot of the time but i think
it's a really good game and i don't say
that just because i personally love it i
think it's also because it actually is a
very good video game you know totally
fair
um so there are uh the games for impact
category um i've not played any of these
games but i wanted to shout them out
because it seems like that's a good
thing that they've done as judged by
some people before your eyes i think
that's the one where you blink
it is i haven't played it but yes it is
it sounds very cool
yes i don't know what happens though um
boyfriend dungeon i'm most familiar with
because of all the controversy
surrounding it but
it also definitely piqued my interest uh
chicory a colorful tail looks beautiful
um life is strange through colors which
none of us have played and no longer
home are all the games nominated in that
category which is like kind of an indie
2.0 category i guess
no longer home actually i haven't either
but i haven't heard of chicory either oh
no i've heard of chicory it's really
really nice it looks beautiful nice
looking yeah yeah it's um yeah yeah
right interesting destiny is not in best
ongoing
it doesn't deserve to be to be honest
with you because as i said it's just
impossible to recommend this game and in
terms of all the [ __ ] that's going on
around it it's it's yeah but i've been
i've been looking for an excuse to get
back into it i just haven't i just i
can't find it with everything that's
going on i i acknowledge that there are
really great things about the game i
just
bungee just hasn't done a good job of
pulling
all players back in or even new players
into it um but i hope they'll manage to
do that eventually
very true i live vicariously with
destiny through all my friends who play
it yeah yeah you got all these crazy
complicated things and i'm like nice
dude that sounds sick
for you yeah
i'm really glad i'm not going to do that
oh actually one other one sable did you
guys disable this year i did not play
it's so beautiful it's so nice to play
it just really nails that like sense of
discovery that like what's over there
because it's so unguided so free form um
i really recommend it it was it's
definitely on my game of the year list
to be honest with you i really loved it
okay it looks really good i've always
like every time i sold it i was i was
very excited about it um still very
excited about seafood we spoke about
that last time
yeah yeah most anticipated
category did anyone play shin megami
tensei
not yet uh that's at the top of my i did
play four and i'm excited for five i
just haven't had time uh but i'm getting
into it big old beefy rpg
yeah this is
like the dark souls of uh jrpgs like
this is like this is tough tough uh
stuff um and it's a lot about exploiting
weaknesses and keeping that vicious
cycle going and if you know if if you
can't then enemies can you know one or
two shot you it's like that level of
intensity but it's it's really fun to
overcome those challenges and that's
based on what i played in four i'm
assuming five is in that vein
it looks more gorgeous now i'm genuinely
pumped to play it oh yeah i wanted to
but tales of a rise took up all my time
and that's i hear great things about it
yes that's that's also nominated for rpg
i think it is
i just bought that i have been like
wanting to make time for it for so long
because it just looks so cool it just
has this like thing about it you're like
man that looks like a cool game to play
you know yeah so i bought it but i
haven't haven't played it yet so uh did
you guys play lost judgement this
uh i played a little bit of it yeah it's
great
but they're always [ __ ] great well i
didn't really like that
to be clear i've already played two
hours
okay so i i didn't play a lot of it but
i i thought it was dope but i'm so
easily impressed by any yakuza
did you like it jay i i did i really
liked your video though i think all
right
like i was like okay he's right that's
fine okay that's what i do when i watch
your videos after i after i make my
video i watch your video and i go okay
all right
there's one reason that i am very happy
there's one reason to be happy that the
like ratio or dislike count has been
removed from youtube and it is my loss
judgment review which is a very very
unpopular review but that's okay you
know you can't but there's a skateboard
in this one how could you there is a
skateboard
so yeah it's just very awkward to use
oh god you go you go up on the side on
the sidewalk and it's like no you have
to get off now you're like but it's
skateboarding it's like real life it's
fun
yeah that's right clubs come straight
away and yell at you skateboarding
looking at the best fighting category
one anticipating anticipated game that
comes to mind is the smash brothers but
it's all warner brothers characters yeah
what's that called
multiverses
multiple verses what [ __ ] garbage
name is that but it is like
that
cool name
we should cash
there's actually you know voice acting
from the original
actors like nickelodeon all-stars brawl
like it feels so dead when you're
playing it because there's just nothing
from the properties and no voice and no
nothing and like smash brothers a huge
part of like why i'm so into it is just
how
much personality they inject like sora
they just like i mean god he plays just
like he does in kingdom hearts it's
crazy but you know the stages and the
music and the voice acting it's all
there and it's totally angry america
they got kevin conroy for multiverses
didn't they yeah
yeah they did so cool they got the the
movie shaggy to play uh uh shout out to
lillard yeah yeah yeah i mean that's
wild now it's just about you know the
gameplay being on point it would be
great to see some of that next week at
the game is it next week
it is right
next thursday
yeah yeah
oh where did the year go oh god oh crazy
i know i i have trouble playing fighting
games i can't do any rapid rapid thumb
movement um which is a huge bummer but i
know a lot of people also really loved
guilty gear this year yes yeah i hope
yeah i think that might take it
i think that's the one that i've heard
most about this year in terms of
fighting people and i love that yeah
yeah just all over twitter and like
everything and fighting game fans like
we ever play this i'm like i don't play
fighting games sadly but looking at how
cool guilty gear looks i wish i believe
you
yeah
fighting games are like a vocation man
you just it's it's like it's a choice
that you'd make to have that life it's
definitely a community it's a lifestyle
you know what i mean sorry yeah that
makes sense um are there any other games
anyone wants to to mention
so yeah
little nightmares too oh man
it was an early that was an early in the
year one
also very good and it's it that one
sucks again recency bias because of the
amount of hype that there was for that
people were really excited about it and
then it just came and went
such a big yeah i love both those games
they're so good so creepy but wonderful
it's a very good shout um
god i don't even know what my top five
list looks like i just i know my top
three and i know inscription it's right
up there yeah but otherwise i'm like i
don't ask
uh it's a stressful man
from most anticipated which one do you
think will win there's eldon ring god of
war ragnarok horizon uh breath of the
wild two and starfield you really have
to ask
i'm so certain i know which game will
win this
yeah
well
what go on what do you think absolutely
elden rick there is no way that that
doesn't get voted out to the moon as
much as i would love god of war ragnarok
to take it i'm sure you were too young
um i i think that there is like
there's just no you can't compete with
france i agree like i think it is gonna
be elven ring but even then breath of
the wild is like if we had seen more of
it maybe it could be more of a contender
um starfield's also pretty opaque
horizon i don't think can take it just
by virtue of similarity to previous
horizons not that it looks that similar
but you know i wonder if the fact that
people got to actually play elden rink
through that closed network test is that
gonna
you know make it more of the most
anticipated game or oh i've kind of seen
enough of it now where i know i'm gonna
because it's in current conversation
yeah that's true yeah i mean even it's
been in current conversation like every
day even though they just didn't release
a trailer for two years or whatever
from fans have one purpose in life to
keep it in the conversation
they will not be stopped they will not
rest yeah i feel like there's no way
elden ring doesn't doesn't win and but
like to be fair though i think we
compare the sales of something like god
of war and that's what like let's say is
it 20 million units for god of war how
many units has got it was sold right no
i would think god would have outsold
second nope yeah but no what i what i'm
saying is i don't know that like from
games sell like in excess of 10 million
units or whatever maybe i'm wrong about
that but i always remember them selling
somewhere between 5 and 10. i think
you're probably right yeah and i think
your big sony exclusives are like 15 to
20. you know so
sold
it looks like the most recent statistic
is over 19.5 million units yeah then if
we do what like dark souls 3 seems like
the best game i'd probably say would
probably be like the longest so
uh dark souls 3's 10 million copies yeah
vertical 3 is multi-platform that's
that's and but it's also
not a new ip which i feel like kind of
cuts it down a bit uh bloodborne i don't
know how to tell how much it's sold
i mean it says two million copies in
2015.
but my point is that
sorry guys
i was gonna say eldon ring has the
branding power of george rr that's true
that's true
it's very smart marketing
yeah he probably just like penned like
wrote three names on a napkin and then
handed it to miyazaki it's like that's
all i need for you man i just need to
better they're just using them
you're right that like statistically in
theory
uh more people have played god of war
than have played elden ring but of the
voting body for that sure yeah it's
still gonna be people who have played
from soft games and even then i feel
like
even if you've never played a fromsoft
game before it's like you have to vote
for ellen ring it's like it feels
stressful now exactly
exactly yeah so part of the culture um
yeah well i would love to go right now
please go vote for god
do it
[Laughter]
uh no bias involved for either of us
yeah no of course not um but uh the the
sequel to breath of the wild i think it
would be the closest second uh in my
opinion but i don't know god of war also
would be very close i don't think it
would be star field horizon i'm excited
for that game i don't think that one
i think so too it's those three yeah i
think are the top three yeah i think the
only reason zelda doesn't take it is
because we haven't seen it
it is not in current conversation um
but it's also the fact that you you
haven't seen too much of it that makes
you all the more like that's true if you
would literally ask me you're so good i
have the most anticipation for it
because i haven't seen it right yeah so
who knows we take the word literally
there's also the best esports game but
those are basically ongoing games
esports athletes none of them do any of
you guys play any mobile games this year
um i did because of uh the indycade jury
that i was on oh yeah a few
um mobile games let me see if any of
them are on this list
i played that league of legends wild
rift port if anyone hasn't played that
yet if you guys like lee because i
actually like league so um
and it's an incredible port like it's
just captures so much of league and it
just condenses it down and it's so
playable on mobile so i know it's like
league is a massive meme i mean i make
that joke every week on my show but uh
at the end of the day like it's still a
pretty amazing thing to have in your
hands and shows you what mobile can be
capable of i mean arcane really popping
off right yeah man really hitting hard
right now um i don't remember the name
of the mobile games that i played which
is devastating
none of them are on my game of the year
list in the past like i don't give a
[ __ ] like if it's like if i play it and
i like it yeah i'll put it on my list i
love monument valley i haven't played it
one and two i thought that that both of
those games are awesome and and
exclusively mobile yeah there are
definitely some great games on mobile i
loved pokemon go i think i had it on my
game of the year lsd it came out too i
feel like in this group uh you may not
have heard about it it's called arc
nights it's uh it's a visual novel slash
tactics game and the story's just
supposed to be amazing my brother got me
into it
um and so that's kind of what i played i
feel like a niche people a group of
people in the chat might know what i'm
talking about um but it's also very
gotcha based as well so i'm like yeah
that coming back and forth to it yeah
mobile games absolutely have a ton of
value
not arguing against it um but yeah of
this list i mean i feel like genshin is
going to win of the things that uh yeah
easily yeah yeah it seems pretty nice
shadow legends
yeah so what is what is league of
legends wild rift what is it what kind
of game is it no it's literally just
league of legends but mobile like that's
oh yeah like but but and that sounds
like oh well how did they mess it up and
it must be some kind of dumbed down
kitty version or whatever no just trust
me when you play it it captures 95
percent of league of legends but they
managed to do it on touchscreen with
mobile it's amazing it's one of the best
proof of concepts for what mobile is
capable of and also it's not out this
year but i played diablo immortals beta
i don't know if any of you played it i
know it's cool to hate diablo model i
get it i played it you know but it's a
good video game i like it you know i'm
going to tell you right now and when
people get their hands on it they will
see for themselves that this is a good
video game so yeah don't you have phones
i i actually have i i like it too um i
don't know i think i played it at the
event uh at that blizzcon
when everyone was mad and i was like
game's pretty good though
conflicting
but it happens um all righty this was
super fun i feel like we could talk
forever it's not hard to do uh thank you
guys for joining me again thank you i
appreciate it it should be interesting
to see how everything shapes up next
week and if you guys figure out what
your game of the years are let me know
because we're all still kind of like
weird
yeah uh ralph where can people find you
uh i am
skill up aka shillop i have a youtube
channel you can google it and you'll
find me and uh
anything you're working on right now
that you wanna i'm working on desk loop
video
uh which is gonna be live next week as
well as another game which i'm not
allowed to talk about exactly right
that'll be live next week
i know what that is and i'm excited
jake how about you
uh during the day you can find me on
game ranks i make the before you buy
videos and a friday news show every
friday i've never taken a day off i'm
really tired
and at night you can find me on my
youtube channel jake baldino right now
i'm cooking on a sam raimi spider-man
video i like cried three times during
the video and i'm like editing around it
uh should be pretty good cool nice i'm
so tuning in for that that'd be freaking
awesome uh young how about you
uh youtube.com slash young yeah as
always and uh if you happen to be a
casting director if you go to
yaoyavio.com you'll find my demo reels
and my resume great stuff
uh but uh mainly yeah my channel
yangya.com or no
youtube.com yeah
and damn it got extra official
yeah yeah
um
and yeah there's some content coming up
cool something that i can't talk about
something i can't and yeah excellent
well yeah thank you guys for joining me
again we should do this again sometime
have a great time it's very fun
and thank you everyone for watching
we'll see you next time
later see you guys
young